From a veteran with a 50-year career to a former
pro wrestler to a few just getting their start,
these are the "Walking Dead"
actors we've lost over the years.
According to the New York Times, Scott
Wilson's breakout role was in the 1967 film
"In Cold Blood," based on the
Truman Capote novel. From there,
he went on to star in 80 films and
television shows throughout his career.
Wilson joined the cast of "The
Walking Dead" in season two,
where he played farmer Hershel Greene, who let
the group of survivors take refuge on his farm.
The character, with his strong moral compass,
was a welcome addition to the show and a good
foil for Rick Grimes. Hershel survived
until halfway through the fourth season,
when he became a victim of the sadistic Governor.
Wilson did film a guest appearance which aired
in season nine after his real-life death in
October 2018. He died of cancer at the age of 76,
but his last scenes provided a fitting
tribute to both the man and the character.
"I know it's been hard."
"It has."
Russell Comegys was no stranger to the
industry when he was cast in his very brief
role in "The Walking Dead." He has made many
appearances in films, such as "The Lucky One"
and the 2004 version of "The Punisher,"
and shows such as "The Vampire Diaries."
Unfortunately, his career was cut short.
He was in a third-season episode of "The Walking
Dead," playing a hitchhiker. When Rick, Carl,
and Michonne drive to retrieve more weapons, they
pass a man, played by Comegys, on the road. They
speed past him, despite his pleas that they stop.
This scene demonstrates that the survivor group
couldn't risk taking on anyone new. The promising
actor died at the age of 45 in 2017 when,
according to news station WTOC, he and another
person were killed in a rollover car accident.
Dango Nguyen was just getting started
in his acting career when he appeared
on "The Walking Dead." With two TV
episodes and one film to his credit,
Nguyen appeared in seven episodes of
the third season of "The Walking Dead."
Acting was his third career after professional
wrestling and almost 20 years as a firefighter.
Athens-Clarke County Fire and Emergency Services
announced his death on its Facebook page.
Nguyen died at age 48 from cancer in
2019. He played a bodyguard of the
Governor and clashed with Rick's group in
Woodbury. His experience led him to parts
in "The Originals" and "MacGyver," and he also
completed stunts in several films and movies,
including "Mile 22," "NCIS:
New Orleans," and "Insatiable."
"The Walking Dead" was Rodney M. Hall's
first-ever credit according to IMDb.
Hall appeared in the second episode of the
first season of "The Walking Dead" as a walker.
The episode featured Rick and Glenn slathering
guts all over themselves to get through a crowd
of walkers, Hall included. It is difficult
to pick him out of this large undead crowd,
but he did complete a few other
appearances before his death in 2021.
Hall also had parts in "Franklin & Bash,"
"Drop Dead Diva," "The Underlying," and
"Devil's Knot." Not much is known
about his life between his last
screen appearance in 2013 and his death
at age 50 from an apparent drug overdose.
His memorial announcement requested
donations to drug and alcohol facilities.
Moses J. Moseley was 31 at the time of his
death. His roles were mostly uncredited before
appearing on "The Walking Dead," but one of
them was for "The Hunger Games: Catching Fire."
His real claim to fame came when he was in
six episodes throughout the early seasons of
"The Walking Dead." Moseley played Mike, who
was one of Michonne's jawless pet zombies.
"I made it so they couldn't
bite. Couldn't scratch.
I tied chains around their necks. It was insane."
After the show, he appeared in guest roles on
several other shows. He died from a gunshot
wound to the head in January 2022. According to
Today, his autopsy was not conclusive. This makes
his manner of death still unconfirmed, even though
he was found in his car with the gun in his lap.
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please dial or text 988 to speak with
The National Suicide Prevention Lifeline. You
can also seek help by visiting 988lifeline.org.